people but let me begin I'm gonna
introduce this topic so I show you
something now I'm gonna show you do not
because I expect you guys to know it but
because I have the maturity to insert
this particular character is in my head
so you probably you probably are too old
to know these people but it's not to the
G it's the Gruffalo
reason 1 this is the Gruffalo's a oh I
don't know if any of you guys are seen
as before the story surrounding
particularly the Gruffalo's child in
history story the story about the
Gruffalo's child is a story of fear
theories like the theme of the story ok
and what happens is the Gruffalo he
tells his child you need to stay away
from this big dangerous part of the
forest because there's the big bad Mouse
in that pod of course right and he tells
him all these scary things about the big
bad Mouse and he starts to be he's not
storing pictures on this cave wall and
he's like okay this is big terrifying
creature and that's why I've got to stay
away from the forest now he's the thing
many people not just children even
adults are scared of numbers look at
numbers in a groove
that's not sort of gives me the
heebie-jeebies okay and people literally
sometimes have a physical response to it
okay but as you might be able to
anticipate right in the story as we know
mice are actually not very fearsome
creatures the Gruffalo's child ends up
meeting a mouse and he's like oh you're
a master problem do you know about the
big bad Mouse and the mass realizes
what's happened right and he goes ahead
and he climbs up on a tree and he says
okay - The Gruffalo I'll go wait over
here and the big bad Mouse will
uses their shadows and sounds and
trickery to make good ruffles child
think that he's met the big bad Mouse
and runs off terrified okay but as you
can tell as we do audience know the mass
is not terrifying
the big bad Mouse is an illusion not
actually scary but the fear that we have
these things are real right and that's
what the story is about now I think
numbers are very similar okay
people are scared of numbers but nobody
just like mice they're not scary in
themselves but our fear of the numbers
can be real okay
now I think I'm convinced the way to
overcome our fear of numbers if we have
it is just to get used to working with
them and understanding them and that's
what this topic is about that's why it's
called working with numbers the whole
idea behind this topic is to get
comfortable with numbers and realize
they can be brought down to sizes
they're not scary things at all okay so
underneath this heading I would like you
to write three acronyms three acronyms
okay there are very simple acronyms
right there big letters Mac attack how
to talk through each of these in turn
and you'll see we're working with
numbers fits into this backpack and
count
Mack nothing to do with that one
Mack stands for mentally assisted
calculations mentally assistant
calculations these are calculations that
we can do in our minds right no other
assistance required 1 + 1 2 + 3 4 times
5 we can do all of these I hope it's 20
mentally assisted calculations right the
things you can do simply with the power
of your mind okay so the example I think
we can do 4 times 5 without any extra
things replace it's 20 pack takes things
a step further it's not mentally
assistant calculations it's paper
assistant operations
so think about if we just leave this
problem a little more complex if you
said a four times five
I had 47 times five okay
now by the time we get to the end of
this you know this kind of calculation
which is obviously a little cardamom
this you probably need some paper to
like write it out put okay four times
this carry the two blah blah blah okay
so you would use some paper as kind of
like an extension of your mind right
because your mind is only so large and
it's like all these numbers are starting
to get too big for my head right if I
put another number on you you're like oh
no way I cannot do this in my mind right
I need something of paper I can write it
down and the working it's always like
I'm outsourcing some of them like mental
space I need for this onto paper I'm
using it literally as like a part of my
an extra-high my brain okay so we use
paper to assist us mostly what do you
think access ok very good
calculator assisted calculations now you
might think what's a bit on that's a bit
redundant you've saved the same thing
twice calculator calculations right what
other kind of calculations are there did
you know that calculator that word it
didn't used to refer to an object it
used to refer to a job there were people
and they would grow up that they would
leave school and they would become
calculators that was the job that's what
they got paid to do because these things
didn't exist right but now they do now
let me give you a quick example I'm just
gonna keep on going further right if I
said to you 473 times 5122
okay probably with patience we could do
this on paper but it's just starting to
get a bit silly we have this power at
our disposal and this is the reason we
use it now here's the danger here's how
these things relate to each other
now that you have calculators it's very
easy to kind of throw sort of you know
even with powered say whoo ha ha
I have calculators I'm going to use a
calculator for everything but there's a
danger there's a danger okay because
some of you might say okay yeah clearly
I'll do that on calculator yeah but then
they start to go to something like
yesterday he could do it on paper
but I've got a calculator so I'm gonna
do that on calculator right but as you
start to do more things with a
calculator this starts to get wake up
right I don't know if anyone's seen
these pictures of astronauts in the
International Space Station right and in
the International Space Station because
gravity's not really well it's acting
you're maybe a different way than
exactly with us we have to use energy to
stand up but they just kind of float
there all right so because they're not
using all the muscles that we have used
every day just to you know move around
their muscles do something called
atrophy atrophy right that's an
important way you should write it down
and look it up after if it means when
you don't use something like a muscle
your body's like what am i what am i
spending energy and eating food to keep
this muscle alive right I don't need
this muscle like I haven't I haven't
stood up for days weeks however long
they've been on the space station and so
exstrophy happens the body says I'm
gonna strip down this muscle and I'm
gonna make it smaller right so atrophy
happens and if you don't use your mental
assistive calculations if you mind then
this will become smaller and smaller so
and before you know it and I've seen it
people are gonna say oh four times five
hold on hold on let me check that one
okay yeah all right oh good it's 20 okay
you don't want to go there
you want to actually rather than
expanding this and getting this smaller
you want to go in the opposite direction
you guys are getting smarter every day
you're becoming more capable your mind
can do more and more every day you're
here so we want to expand this and this
topic this topic will be teaching you
strategies to help you make this
bigger of course we're always going to
use this it's going to be super useful
okay it's great so you can check things
it's great so you can be accurate but
you want to take the muscle of your mind
and work it that's what mathematics is
about